hi I'm Annie whoo and I'm a mathematics
teacher I think it's a really common
struggle that many people students and
adults alike have experienced that they
maybe were encounter encounter a problem
and they couldn't arrive at that final
number or the final number they arrived
that wasn't the one that the teacher was
searching for and for me I think that's
that that experience there of not being
able to get there it sort of really
takes the wind out of someone's
mathematical reasoning and thinking and
self-concept because how do they end
that experience they just end up feeling
like a failure I think back to you know
the lessons of storytelling and you can
have you could have a movie or a play or
a book that has a kind of the average
beginning and okay middle and it has a
great ending then you come out of it
thinking that was amazing and conversely
it's true you can start off with a great
punch and have a very amazing surprising
middle but if you end in a way that is
dissatisfying
and sort of leaves you deflated you go
away from that experience very much
disliking it and that's there's an
emotional sort of resonance there I
would like that was not was not a great
experience and many people feel
mathematics that way they forget about
the journey that they took to understand
ah what what all these pieces how did
they all fit together and then I made
some routine arithmetic error that meant
my number at the end was 10 times larger
than it was supposed to be and just
because my decimal point was in the
wrong spot I feel like all the things
that I went through before were
meaningless and so I think that emphasis
on the end point is dangerous in that
way at the end point is not you know
worthless it's really it's one of the
most powerful things about mathematics
that it can solve problems that you
might think are insurmountable but
through the application of logic and
reasoning we can get there but if we
emphasize that at the expense of all of
these other things all the reasoning and
thinking and collaboration and talking
and dialogue to arrive at that point I
think we saw our students a false bill
of goods about what mathematics is
[Music]